This lecture is about the how to evaluate
the text retrieval system when we have
multiple levels of judgments.
In this lecture we will continue the
discussion of evaluation.
We're going to look at the how to
evaluate the text retrieval system when
we have multiple level of judgments.
So, so far we have talked the about binary
judgments.
That means a document is judged as
being relevant or non relevant.
But earlier we also talk about the
relevance as a matter of degree, so we
often can distinguishing
very high relative documents.
Those are very useful documents from
your moderately relevant documents.
They are ok,
they are useful perhaps.
And further from non relevant
documents, those are not useful.
So imagine you can have ratings for
these pages.
Then you would have multiple levels of
ratings.
For example here I show example of
three levels, 3 for relevant
sorry 3 for very relevant, two for marginally
relevant and one for non relevant.
Now how do we evaluate search engine
system using these judgments?
Obviously the map doesn't work.
Average precision doesn't work.
Precision and recall doesn't work
because they rely on binary judgments.
So let's look at some top ranked
results when using these judgments,
right?
Imagine the user would be mostly care
about the top 10 results here.
Right?
And we marked the
reading levels or relevance levels for
these documents as shown here, 32113,
etc.
And we call these "Gain".
And the reason why we call it "Gain"
is because the measure that we're
introducing is called nDCG(Normalized
Discounted Cumulative Gain).
So this gain basically can measure how
much gain of relevant information the
user can obtain by looking at each
document.
Alright, so looking at the first
document that the user can gain three
points.
Looking at the non random document,
the user would only gain one point.
By looking at the moderately relevant
or marginal relevant documents, the
user would get two points.
Etc. So this gain intuitively matches
the utility of a document from a user's
perspective.
Of course, if we assume the user stops
at the 10 documents and we're looking
at the cut off at 10, we can look at
the total game of the user.
And what's that?
Well, that's simply the sum of these
and we call it a cumulative gain.
So if the user stops at the position one
where there's just three, if the user
looks at the another document, that's  3 +
2.
If the user looks at the more documents,
then the cumulative gain is more.
Of course, this is at the cost of
spending more time to examine the list.
So cumulative gain gives us some idea
about the how much total gain
the user would have if the user
examines all these documents.
Now in nDCG we also have another letter
here, D discounted.
Cumulative gain.
So why do we want to do discounting?
Well, if you look at this cumulative
gain, there is one deficiency, which is
it did not consider the rank position
of these documents.
So, for example, looking at the this sum
here.
And we only know there is one highly
relevant document one marginally
relevant document, two non relevant
documents.
We don't really care where they are
ranked.
Ideally we want these two to be ranked
on the top and which is the case here.
But how can we capture that intuition?
Well, we have to say this is 3 here.
is not as good as this three on
the top.
And that means the contribution of the
gain from different positions has to be
weighted by their position, and this is
the idea of discounting, basically.
So we're going to say well, the first one
doesn't need to be discounted, because
the user can be assumed to always see
this document, but the second one, this
one will be discounted a little bit
because there's a small possibility
that the user wouldn't notice it.
So we divide this gain by the weight
based on the position, so log of 2. Two
is the rank position of this document.
And when we go to the third position,
we discount even more because the
normalizes log of three and so on, so
forth.
So when we take a such a sum than a
lower rank document will not contribute
contribute that much as a highly ranked
document.
So that means if you for example switch
the position of this, let's say this
position and this one, and then you
would get more discount if you put.
For example, very relevant document
here, as opposed to here.
Imagine if you put three here, then
it would have to be discounted, so it's
not as good as if we would put the
three here.
So this is the idea of discounting.
OK, so now at this point that we have
got that discounted cumulative gain for
measuring the utility of this ranked
list with multiple levels of judgments.
So are we happy with this?
Well, We can use this rank systems.
Now, We still need to do a little bit more
in order to make this measure
comfortable across different topics.
And this is the last step.
And,
By the way, here we just showed the DCG
at the ten right?
So this is the total sum of DCG.
Overall these 10 documents.
So the last step is called the N
normalization and if we do that then we
will get a normalized DCG.
So how do we do that?
Well the idea here is we're going to
normalize DCG by the ideal DCG at the
same cut off.
What is the ideal DCG?
This is the DCG
of ideal ranking.
So imagine if we have 9 documents in
the whole collection.
Rated 3 here.
And that means in total we have 9
documents rated 3.
Then our ideal rank, the Lister would
have put all these nine documents on
the very top.
So all these would have to be 3 and
then this will be followed by a two
here because that's the best we could
do after we have run out of threes.
But all these positions would be
threes.
Right?
So this will be an ideal ranked list.
And then we can compute the DCG for
this ideal ranked list.
So this would be given by this formula
that you see here, and so this ideal DCG
would then be used as the
normalizer DCG..., here.
And this ideal DCG will be used as
a normalizer.
So you can imagine now normalization
essentially is to compare the actual
DCG with the best DCG you can possibly
get for this topic.
Now, why do we want to do this?
Well, by doing this will map the DCG
values into a range of zero through
one, so the best value or the highest
value for every query would be one.
That's when your ranked list is in fact the
ideal list.
But otherwise, in general you will be
lower than one.
Now, what if we don't do that?
Well, you can see this transformation
or this normalization doesn't really
affect the relative comparison of
systems for just one topic, because
this ideal DCG is the same for all the
systems, so the ranking of systems
based on only DCG would be exactly the
same as if you rank them based on the
normalized DCG.
The difference however is when we have
multiple topics.
because if we don't do normalization,
different topics will have different
scales of DCG.
For a topic like this one we have 9
highly relevant documents.
The DCG can get really high, but
imagine in another case,
There are only two very relevant
documents in total, in the whole
collection.
Then the highest DCG that any system
could achieve for such a topic will
not be very high.
So again, we face the problem of
different scales of DCG values, and we
take an average.
We don't want the average to be
dominated by those high values.
Those are again easy queries, so by
doing the normalization we can avoid
the avoid the problem making all the
queries contribute equally to the
average.
So this is the idea of nDCG.
It's useful for measuring ranked list
based on multiple level
relevance judgments.
So more in the more general way, this is
basically a measure that can be applied
to any rank
the task with multiple level of
judgments.
And
The scale of the judgments can be
multiple.
Can be more than binary, not only more
than binary.
They can be multiple levels like a 1 through
5 or even more depending on your
application.
And the main idea of this measure I
just to summarize is to measure the
total utility of the top K documents.
So you always choose a cut off and then
you measure the total utility and it
would discount the contribution from a
lower ranked document.
And finally it will do normalization to
ensure comparability across queries.